I,
this is intimate.
I was told,
I was told that the biggest problem
tyler,
you're going to have this afternoon is
getting Tony Robin Robins to come out of
his shell.
Okay.
So,
so,
so don't be shy here today.
It's all going to be good.
We were talking backstage and,
and,
and you teed up a question that,
that I think is,
is part of every business owner's
journey and that is the art and science
of overcoming the obstacles that you
face.
They are inevitable.
Yes,
they are existential.
Sometimes they are fear inducing most of
the time.
What do you do when you hit one of the
obstacles?
I think it's,
it's really important.
First of all,
it's great to be with you all here.
I know you've had a full day and I hope
to that's some real value to you in this
brief time.
Um,
I think it's really critical that you
understand that everybody wants to grow
their business and we all go through
different phases,
right?
Just like human beings go through
phases.
You know,
you give birth to your business and
you're an infant and an infant as a run
for survival and cashflow problems or
natural process in most cases in your
running.
Hopefully you get to a teenager or were
now cashflow is not a problem.
You're growing like crazy and then you
have a new problem.
You don't have systems in place and
maybe you get the young adult where you
have to decide what you're not going to
do eventually hopefully get to prime
where you're growing your business
revenues and you're growing your profits
and you've got a professional
organization.
You're not doing it because as long as
you're doing it really you don't have a
business what you have as you're self
employed and there's nothing wrong with
being self employed,
but there whenever you meet someone
who's in businesses stress,
they're always a business operator and
my focus has become a business owner.
How do you do that?
You realize that the choke hold on,
the growth of your business is always
the leader and it's your skills and it's
your psychology and I've found it's 80%
psychology and 20% skills.
You've got to have the marketing skills,
you gotta be able to lead,
you've got to be able to recruit,
you got to do all those things.
But really most importantly,
going to get it through what I call the
threshold of control.
And this to me is the secret to really
succeeding in business.
And it's pretty simplistic.
Uh,
how many of you a snowboard or ski?
Anybody out there?
Some numbers?
Can you give me a sense?
So if you're,
most people are terminally intermediate
when they get in that sport,
right?
You know,
they,
they really never get back.
Good.
They're not really a belonger.
They're kind of you in the middle and
they never get much better.
And I think the reason is they never
pushed themselves beyond what they can
handle,
right?
Uh,
you're,
you're used to Greens or blues and you
find yourself on a double black.
And what happens?
Everything inside you freaks out because
you're a pass,
what I call the threshold of control,
your comfort zone.
And you look down and you go,
I could die doing this.
So now you have two choices.
Either.
Most people slam themself on the ground
and hang on for dear life and try not to
skid off the cliff and at best what you
do with survive or a few people let go
of their fear,
no matter how scary it is and goes I to
go down this thing and there's no other
choice.
And they focus on where they want to go
instead of what they're afraid of and
they find a way to carve.
And once you carve a few of them that
Doba black is your bitch,
right?
You don't have to worry about that
anymore.
And so that's what happens in business.
So for me,
I can remember going and starting my
first business in Vancouver,
British Columbia,
Canada.
I got on the radio show and this person
was a shock jock radio show and I didn't
know it.
And they started attacking me and
saying,
I'm a wire and a charlatan.
You can't do these things.
And this therapist called me up and
said,
you know what?
I've dealt with people forever.
You can't wipe out a phobia in less than
an hour.
It can take seven years.
I've a patient right now,
I've worked with for seven years and
been able will solve this.
And I said,
great,
bring that patient tonight.
I'm doing a free guest event at the
Holiday Inn and all take care of it.
It should take me 10 to 15 minutes
and do it.
I do it.
And I was able to do it.
A wrap the snake around this woman,
she had a snake phobia phobia is an
uncontrollable response.
So because of that I had people coming
to these guests events like crazy and I
thought I hit the home run right.
And I did this big guest event.
There was like a thousand people there
for me would be like,
I don't know,
100,000 people under that right now.
And um,
after I was done,
a bunch of people signed up for my
seminar because I did a free value add
event and then I would invite them to
come spend three days with me.
And this man walks up to me and he's
from immigration.
He goes,
a great seminar.
uh,
I'd like to see your work permit.
I said,
what's a work permit?
You know when you're in beginner,
you can business.
You don't know these things,
right?
He goes,
well,
the work in this country,
you need to work from it.
And he said,
I'll tell you when I got to see you
tomorrow at five 30 I was wanting to
spend with her.
Starts at seven he goes,
you'll,
you'll be fine.
Just you gotta be there at five 30 he
said,
I'm not asking.
It's a requirement.
So I show up at five 30 I wait for half
an hour.
Now I'm starting to stress and finding a
sit down with a guy and he says,
you're taking away Canadian jobs.
They said,
how many Canadian fire walkers are
there?
Come on.
That's what I was doing.
And he said,
no,
you teach nlp skills,
neurolinguistic programming.
And these people have classes of 20
people and you've got a class of 500 and
so they say,
you're taking jobs.
So your event is over.
What do you mean your events?
He goes,
if you walk on that stage tonight,
we will handcuff you and deport you.
This is what I call a threshold with
control.
He says,
you're going to have to get the money
back.
I said,
I can't get the money back.
I spent all the money and put on the
seminar.
It wasn't a good businessman.
I just wanted to help everybody,
right?
So I spent all the money and he goes,
you have no money while you're going to
have to deal with that.
So I walked out of the building,
I have 40 minutes.
People are going to arrive.
I can't go on stage.
What do you do?
I told my three staff members,
two of which were volunteers,
what happened?
They're like,
Ooh.
And I said,
here's what we're doing.
I'm doing this seminar.
And he said,
you're going to go to jail so I'm not
going to jail.
So how close is the board?
True story?
And they said,
well,
this a place called Bellingham,
Washington.
It's about an hour and 40 minutes.
I said,
rent money,
six buses,
and I'll meet the people out front
before they go on the hotels is not a
problem.
I made everybody up front.
He said,
this is a traveling seminar.
It's a surprise,
right?
We're going to
go into America.
He was a three day seminar.
We had to go and come back each day and
night for three days in a row.
I got all the four people to agree to do
it.
And,
and then I got to go here in Washington
at the Holiday Inn there,
and it was,
there was like a bar Mitzvah or a
wedding or some stuff mixed door and it
was so loud you couldn't hear anybody.
And so I said,
just lie on the floor.
Close your eyes is going to hit the ties
you into this shit.
Right?
But so what happened?
Where'd you learn how to get through
that?
Right?
And we learned how to be resourceful
when you realize that your problem is
not a lack of resources,
if not a lack of money or technology or
contacts.
If not,
it's your psychology.
Because the ultimate resource is
resourcefulness and human emotion.
That's what starts wars.
That's what makes a business begin.
That's how you have children.
That's how we end wars.
It's all emotion.
And so what I really learned to do was
how to manage my emotions.
So you know,
once you saw that one,
the next one shows up.
I had somebody,
I started franchise and cup Franchisees
were really upset.
We're wanting people representing on my
side said they didn't make things clear
to them and you know,
it's all bullshit but cost me $5 million
in four years.
I thought the first one was like a
$50,000 challenge and I've got a $5
million challenge and it took all the
money I'd saved in my entire career to
pay that off.
And I was starting over again.
And then I grew from that.
And then I finally got,
you know,
to add a partner in business.
And long story short,
they had a business that was losing $1
million a day and he turned it around
and make it 1.8 billion and Ebitda the
offer be his partner.
And I signed a document saying we're all
joint and several,
there's 40 million in debt.
I figured I had 10 million of the debt
to have 1,000,008 1.8 billion in
infrastructure.
And it turned out my partners,
uh,
two of them were broke.
They weren't billionaires,
they had lost their money and the other
one was the son of a billionaire in his
dad had given them nothing at $5 million
to his band.
I was on the hook shortly after $420
million when they didn't have $120
million.
I forget how to deal with that.
By doing that,
I eventually took my companies to this
year will surpass $6 billion and 33
companies cause I made it through the
threshold of control.
So I want you to know when you see these
big numbers by any entrepreneur,
they all started with blocking and
tackling and they all started with how
do I get both the skill and the more
importantly the psychology,
you can get the skill.
If you can get that part of you that
just doesn't die,
the part of me that finds the way to add
more value than anybody else that you
can keep growing.
Where does the perseverance come from
for you?
Where,
cause the indomitable spirit come from
here.
The title of your book unshakeable.
Where does the,
does the drive come from?
You did not grow up in easy
circumstances.
No,
at all.
No College at all.
No.
All self educated,
self educated,
a household that was not easy.
True.
Is that part of the reason that you are
as perseverance as you are?
As optimistic as
you are,
but maybe it was a way to comp it.
Toot too.
I think it developed moxy.
My,
my mother was a really good woman.
I didn't talk about it when she was
alive and I frankly,
even if she passed,
I didn't talk about it until one day I
was sitting in front of a group of 30
kids that are all are abused by their
parents and,
and I told them that,
you know,
your biography is not your destiny and
you're not defined by what happened.
But I could see in their eyes,
big Paul White,
rich guy,
you know,
he doesn't understand.
And so I told him the whole story.
My mom beating me against the wall,
to my head bled point with itself down
my throat too.
I threw up.
So I think in order to protect my
younger brother and sister,
I had to become a practical psychologist
that drove me and I developed moxy to be
able to deal with stuff.
So that was the gift that my mom had
been the mother I'd wanted to be.
I wouldn't be the man I'm proud to be,
I think so that was the gift in it.
But I think the,
the drive part is falling in love with
your customers.
I love people.
I've always loved people and I hate
suffering because I've suffered and I
loved the white people up and not just
light him up,
pump them up.
I love to have another skill.
Having a tool,
have a system,
you know,
and I do my bootcamps each year for our
business mastery programs.
I guarantee everybody there,
and the day one,
you have $1 million of value in your
opinion.
Or we'll give you,
keep all of this stuff you've got and
we'll give you your money back.
No one ever leaves because I know how to
add that value in the business for those
people.
So I think the drive is the biggest
mistake.
I think businesses make as many
businesses are started by people that
you built a product you love,
and that may still be true for you.
Like you built this great jewelry or you
built this great software or you or
whatever skill set you have.
But the problem is the world changes so
fast now.
I mean,
I'm old enough who remembers the Sony
Walkman?
Anybody ancient and that that product
less than 20 years now product like
basketball,
even last a year,
right?
The competition is too high.
So today if you and I are going to
really succeed,
you got to fall in love with your ideal
customer.
Because look,
I'm sure you know that right now the
economy we have is looking pretty good,
but it's going to correct because we've
done nothing since 2008 set print,
more money and we didn't print money and
we put ones and Zeros and computers.
So there's gonna be some corrections.
And when those happens,
it's going to shake people up.
You need to fall in love with a client
who's going to do well with you even
when the economy goes to hell.
Think about it.
Starbucks,
I was sitting across from our jolts and
had a great conversation and say,
what does he most proud of him?
He said,
he used to say starting starbucks.
Then he said,
now it's surviving 2008 as they closed,
I think it was 1300 stores,
if I remember correctly it for $2
coffee.
So you need to get your ass ready for
winter because it's coming and if you
ever got challenges now,
but if you do,
if you do well in winter,
you'll dominate for the rest of the time
and the way you do well mentor is you
fall in love with your ideal clients and
then you come up with the irresistible
offer for them.
You know Steve Jobs created 99 cent
songs,
but he didn't create that shit.
We all know that we're to come from
WHO's old enough?
Remember Columbia House where you got
like 10 albums for a buck?
Remember that are for corridor and
stuff.
They built a billion dollar company,
Tom Shoes,
shitty product.
I love him.
Great Greg,
what he does,
but two for one,
being able to do something where I get
it and I benefit somebody else.
Brilliant idea,
but the whole company on that,
he didn't build on the product,
he booked it on the mission,
right?
So you need an irresistible offer for
the client who is ideal for you and you
want to fall in love with a client.
Don't fall in love with your product or
service because those need to change.
And if you fall in love with your
product or service,
somebody is going to beat you.
They're going to be anticipated.
I always tell businesses,
there's two businesses you have to run
manage right now.
You have to run the business you're in
because if you don't want him at your
castle,
your challenges are going to bite you.
But you also have to run the business
you're becoming and both businesses you
have to making progress on.
If you get all excited about the future
and all the cool stuff that's coming and
you go work on that and there's no
cashflow,
now you're dead in the water.
If you just work on today,
you're going to wake up and go,
what the hell happened?
My competition beat me.
It's those two sides and my 33
companies.
I look at what the company is now and
what it has to be constantly.
So there were,
were doing the,
you know,
the,
the grunt work,
if you will,
the important day to day work while
we're anticipating the future.
When you were building your businesses
and you've gone through an evolution,
it's all business owners do,
I mean what you were doing 30 years ago
isn't really what you're doing today.
How and when did you know that you were
doing in life what you were meant to do?
Because I think that's part of the quest
of the entrepreneur is to,
is to achieve that.
When did you know it?
How did you know it?
When did I know?
I think I've known you,
I think you know,
the different stages at different levels
at different times.
You know,
it's like,
uh,
I can remember one that stands out from
you and yes,
that pops in my head is uh,
President Clinton calling me.
I was with Peter Guber,
my,
my partner in the sports business and we
both them the yellow AAFC new in the mls
franchise soccer franchise to build a
stadium there.
I was at his home and asked him that and
he says,
the president is on the line for you.
And it was President Clinton and I
picked the phone and I talked to present
for a few minutes and he told me what's
going on.
And I said,
Mister President,
I'm completely honored.
You want me to come visit with you?
And I'd love to,
but I want you to know I'm not a fan.
I said,
uh,
you know,
it was the time when,
which you said the economy stupid.
And then he turned around and all these
things aren't related to the economy and
he looked like a very weak president at
that point.
And I remember Peter Looking at color,
you just told the fucking United States
you're not a fan.
Oh,
you tell him inviting you to come out to
the camp,
David.
But it was great.
I said,
I just,
I want to be sincere.
I love to serve you,
but I'm not,
I'm not a sycophant.
Right.
Yeah.
And so I went there and spend time with
him.
And I think the moment I know that I was
doing what I loved was when there were a
couple of other people,
then they're all trying to get his
attention.
And he and I went through this walk,
you know,
and this deer went by and he was telling
me about all these past presidents.
He was honestly at the time complaining
about how unfair things were.
And I thought,
this is a pressing United States and
these F up
and I'm 31 years old and I got to help
this bastard,
you know?
And then that night he wanted me to stay
and it was new years and I left Aspen
with my family and Peter and I promised
my family and come back.
And I said,
no,
promised my family was present.
I said I'd be happy to work with in the
future and I left leaving the president
when everybody else stayed,
uh,
was a moment I realize I'm doing what
I'm really supposed to do.
I've kept my party straight,
my family still number one,
making contribution is number two.
I'm able to play on the scale that's
global and a male playing this play
scale that matters most,
which is local and family.
I think that would be a moment that
sticks out.
I don't want to spend a lot of time on
this,
but since you brought up the subject of
presidents,
I have to ask you about the current
president.
Yes.
Have you had,
have you advised him and if you haven't,
how would you help him?
Brain transplant?
No,
just kidding.
I know the president quite well.
I've known for many years.
I gave him his first big speech I'm,
I might be to blame.
He wrote about in his book,
he thought he was coming to speak to 200
people in my seminar with 10,000 people.
And you just kind of lost it a little
bit.
Um,
and then his number one piece of
feedback on how to succeed was get a
prenup.
And I thought,
oh my God.
And I know Mrs. Clark.
I Know Mrs. Clinton very well as well.
So,
um,
I had a great difficulty in this last
election because I felt like both
parties lied.
And I think that's extremely hard.
I mean,
everybody goes white lights,
but some were pretty exaggerated and
obviously on both sides.
And so I thought it was a more difficult
time.
Um,
I help people on both sides of the
aisle.
I don't talk about it and way help
unless they talk about it publicly.
Uh,
President Clinton is shared,
you know,
he called me one day and said,
uh,
you know,
I got the overhead speaker.
The president's calling them in my
offices,
big offices in two floors.
I went to the pickup,
the stone,
and sure enough,
it's the secretary and the presence
waiting and says,
Tony,
they're gonna impeach me in the morning.
What should I do?
I was like,
could you call me sooner
morning?
Hey,
what the hell are you going to do?
Right?
So you know,
he said,
what should I do?
And I said,
the answer is not what should they do?
You're asking the wrong question.
The first question you gonna ask is,
what do you want?
Do you want parents,
moms,
dads to have their kids look up to you
or do you want him to stay in office?
I mean,
it's a different outcome.
I said,
if you want to stay in the office,
easy for me.
I'm not a lawyer and I'm not in your
position,
but let's be honest,
you're never going to get thrown out of
office.
There's too many votes on your side.
So I said,
you're going to stay an office if be do
nothing.
But I said,
if you really want to be respected,
I said,
you can share the truth.
You're a lawyer without putting yourself
at risk.
And still get more of the truth out.
And we had a great conversation.
He's near.
That's exactly right.
That's exactly what I do.
So I'll call you back,
I'll call you back in 20 minutes,
some weight and 2030 45 and an hour
later secretary calls me and says,
[inaudible] want you to know he's still
resolving things.
He wants to get back to you.
And then another 30 minutes went by and
thinking like an effecting history here,
right?
And then I saw him standing with all the
Democrats beside him to say,
nope,
we're doing to kind of keep this theme
component and went through things.
So over the years I've had the chance to
work with people on all sides.
And what I think about the current
president is he's terrible communicator.
But I think he actually has some good
ideas.
And I also think he's communicated so
poorly in our world is so,
but now anything he says is seen through
that filter.
If I think you are the nicest man in the
world,
it totally controls my experience of
you.
It has nothing to do with you.
It's my belief.
If you treat me mean one day and we're
best friends,
I'll probably go,
you're having a bad day,
right?
If I can't resolve it with you and who's
ever had a bad day,
when you look,
somebody else thought that about you and
you're just having a bad day,
you know?
So,
but if I think you're a manipulative
bastard and I'm wrong,
but I believe it and you don't treat me
me and you treat me real nice,
what's the first question in our mind?
What does he want?
So your questions,
your belief,
your emotion or your experience has
nothing to do with life.
It's shaped by what you believe in.
Most of you believe what you believe,
not by enduring interacting with these
people personally.
You're doing it through the media and
the media is a great component that
everything's soundbites.
And let's be honest,
it's no longer about informing you.
It's about startling you in farming,
you will never get your attention.
There's too much.
We've got oceans,
you know,
people say that we're living in an
information society that's total
bullshit.
The information society died a long time
ago,
right?
We're drowning in information,
we're starving for wisdom.
And what we get now are sound.
And now people don't,
you know,
it's not news anymore on both sides of
the table.
People basically pretended snooze when
it's all commentary.
And so your perception,
it's like I just had lunch recently with
George W.
Bush.
I brought them out to speak to a,
a group of my funding groups and I bring
up people on both sides of the aisle.
And this year we're working with has an
Obama so you could get him in,
but to give you an idea,
most people their thought they were more
liberal and they were like thinking like
this guy is evil.
And after two hours of conversation
there wasn't a person that you're like,
oh,
thought that right.
They really liked him,
but like I was getting on as decisions
and they got to see why he made the
decisions he did.
And when you see the why,
instead of all the bullshit you hear and
the generalizations that he's an evil
guy,
you start to go,
wow,
I might've made a different,
different incentive.
I might not have without information
that he had at that time.
I asked him about the current president
that it was still during the election
when this is occurring.
And I,
I said,
obviously I know you wanted your brother
to win.
And I admired person Bush for never
attacking the past present.
He never attacked President Obama.
It was,
it was a class act even when he
disagreed.
So he told me privately what he felt.
And then he said,
Tony,
I remember when Nixon was elected and he
said,
I fought.
That was the end of the American
presidency.
I mean,
the pressing United States is God.
I mean he's,
he's,
he's the wrong thing.
And he said he didn't destroy it.
He didn't.
And he said,
so here's what I figured out.
The office is bigger than the occupant.
And I really believe that's true.
I think if you want to go home tonight
with a little bit of comfort inside,
go back to that truth.
The office is bigger than the occupant
and you'll see it when he does things.
And then there's a judicial branch that
balances it.
And,
and I think we're in a situation where
the biggest challenge we have as a
society is we demonize the other side on
almost every issue,
right?
They used to be that,
you know,
congressmen and senators would go fight
like crazy on the floor and then they go
have a beer together.
Now your radioactive,
if you talk to somebody and that's huge.
I,
I met Mr Gorbachev,
I got a chance to fly him for four and
half hours and I asked him what ended
the Cold War and he said at the end of
demonization,
you said it used to be you guys were
attacking us and everything he did was
evil.
We were the evil empire and we knew you
were evil.
And he said one day said,
I was sitting there with President
Reagan.
He was lecturing me and he said,
I could feel the anger,
I could feel my face burning red.
I was so mad.
And I said to him,
you are not my teacher and I am not your
student and you will not lecture me.
And he said,
then I lectured him.
I'm able some capital.
I remember going back and forth and he
said,
so that's one of the Cold War.
And I said,
you know,
that's really great answer,
but I'm with you for four hours and I
want to know the moment.
What's the moment I'm spending this time
with history?
What's the,
what changed the world?
Because most of us forget,
that's probably take away terrorism.
Terrorism is nothing compared to the
level of nuclear salt the USSR and the
US had at that stage,
biggest change we've had and he thought
from old talking mountain.
He showed this great moment with bay,
said he hit his leg,
he's talking to the interpreter,
but he recognized us,
understand why the English,
he's smacking his legging giggling like
a little kid.
He goes,
I will tell you the moment he said we
were having this fight back and forth,
back and forth,
was lecturing him.
He was lecturing me and you all of a
sudden you just stood up like this and
he said,
this is not working.
He turned and walked three steps away
and he turned back and said,
can we start fresh?
My name is Rod.
And to have that same impact they did on
you this now he said he was laughing
uncontrollable.
He goes,
I knew I could do business with this
man.
You have the love the man.
And Minnie said,
Reagan also knew the Gorbachev loves
children and there were no children
going to go to the USSR.
Right?
So the union and Reagan brought a group
of children over and let them be in the
care of Gorbachev and he said the
completely changed the game for him.
So it was a moment,
just a moment of breaking someone's
pattern and that works in an intimate
relationship.
It works in a business challenge,
but it also works out of scale of
society in history.
I want to go to audience questions and I
hope you all had sent some to the iconic
tour Hashtag.
I'll go to those in just a sec,
but,
but from politics back to to
entrepreneurial is in the
entrepreneurship,
you've built businesses,
you've faced business challenges,
you have talked to people like the
people in this room,
entrepreneurs.
What do they ask you most and what do
you tell them?
Time.
Time seems to be the largest issue.
How many of you have time issues and run
your business having to have a life and
your time?
Does he show hands out there who feels
like that's there?
So you can see it's about nine years ago
and some people are just too tired to
raise their hand.
But the issue of time is not
the real issue.
The real issue is that they're operating
as an operator,
not an owner.
And so when I start to do in the
beginning you have to do both,
right?
But when I start to do is show them how
you have to be able to break off and get
other people to do things.
But more importantly,
I teach people.
I do a,
you know,
a five day bootcamp,
I called business mastery with a couple
of times a year.
Can we bring in businesses from all over
the world?
Literally.
And we have people just starting a
business and we have people with,
you know,
this is something they're doing a
billion,
2,000,000,003.
And what you find is that there's a
common pattern amongst all these group
of people where they find if they're,
if it's a small business,
they do everything because they figured
that that was the only one can do it or
they tried someone else and they fail.
But that happens in every business.
You have to begin to leverage yourself
or you're just going to be self employed
and you'll never have the scalability.
A business is a system that adds value
even when you're not there and you as a
leader have to get good enough to both
hire people and train people so that
you're not a manager.
A manager works with people to make sure
they get the job done while you're
there,
but if you have to be there,
there's a cry run 33 companies.
I mean every four days I'm on a plane
train helicopter on stage,
somewhere on average in a year and I got
33 companies.
There's 12 I managed directly,
but I couldn't do that by management.
I do it by leadership.
I build leaders who can make their own
decisions.
I hire people that are the best of the
best.
Now in the beginning that's hard cause
you have no money,
right?
So you hire the best,
it's called you and you pay them
nothing.
And then now you try to hire other
people and what do you do?
You hire your friends,
which you know is a disaster because
they're not as skilled and you love them
and it's hard to manage them.
And then I hired people that were really
talented but they were mean.
You know,
they didn't share my values.
And so eventually you get to that place
where you can find the right people.
But I think the most important secret
for the growth of any business,
and the question that got us on how to
go over the time,
and the answer is you've got to take two
hours,
many minutes a week with your team of
one,
two,
three,
2000 and you got to meet where you work
on the business.
And I teach people a format called seven
seven where there's seven areas of a
business that you cannot miss.
Marketing,
sales optimization,
the financials,
culture.
And I'll make sure that each week you
and your team focus on that.
Not been bathed in a business.
But how do we strengthen our marketing,
not just for this run,
but overall how we build the brand?
What do we do to change our sales
process?
How do we optimize the business?
How do we spend no money and grow the
business 30% in the next three to six
months?
And when you take small markers in the
business that are critical and your
improve them five,
10 15% that you do 12 of them,
you'll grow your business 120 130% and
40% because there's a compounding
impact.
You don't just get the improvement
you've made.
So I try to help businesses to make
those changes so that,
so you have time to think and be
strategic.
Because if you're just running,
how many of you are stressed?
I'll be honest,
I'll be honest.
If you had today being here and not
being at your business,
how many pills?
Some stress in your business being away
even for a day.
Okay,
write down,
I'm a business operator.
F that I'm going to come a business
owner.
You've got to be,
yeah.
Let's go to a question from the
audience.
Uh,
what would the 13 year old version of
yourself say to you today with
conviction and be flat wrong about,
let's see,
we're going to get a 30 year old.
Well,
first of all,
he's dead,
so he's not gonna say shit today.
I buried him a long time ago was the
fifth 57.
Um,
I would say,
um,
I would say the 30 year old would say,
this is what we're going to do this
year.
And it would be these huge numbers.
And I develop a principle around the
time I was 30 is most of us overestimate
work we're going to do in a year.
And we underestimate,
we're going to do in a decade and a
decade happens that fast.
You'll blink,
your eyes will be here.
So I really,
truly,
I,
everything I do as long term,
I think it's the biggest challenge we
have in your corporate America is always
looking for the next quarter instead of,
you know,
the best business people,
the Marc Benioff's,
the Steve Wynn's.
Peter Guber is and people that I hang
with,
they all are decade long people.
When I was 14 I said,
this is how my life's going to go.
I decided,
I sat in my twenties I'm going to help.
I want to have the skill to help anyone
changed their lives.
If I'm committed to,
they're committed,
it's going to be done a hobby ability.
So I got to build to that,
which I did and I said in my thirties
and 14 I said,
I'll do that with groups of people.
It's been a one on one and then in my
forties I'll do a big groups in my
fifties I'll do it with companies and my
six p's,
I'll either do it in government as a
servant there or in a religious context
cause I'm a spiritual person.
But I don't tell people what to believe
religiously.
But at that point I've lived long
enough,
maybe a well,
well do you have a run for office,
a Iul?
I would've said yes.
Now the answer is no.
I've served on both sides of the island.
It's not really about the office,
it's about fundraising right now.
So much of the time I would not do that
unless I ran with in my own money on,
you know,
maybe a small number of friends.
But at this stage I think it would
disrupt my wife's life so much.
I'm a very public person and she's not
and I feel bad for her.
So I don't think that would be right.
Let's go to Jeff Collins question.
If mindset is the key or a key,
how do you shift your mindset?
I was going to ask a question that's
related to that and that is uh,
you're now,
but when you say your top of the world,
but you're a confident guy,
what do you do?
What do you do when you have self doubt
and that's sort of how your mindset,
I think that you deal with self doubt.
I will,
I don't have a lot of it at this stage,
but,
but it's shocking.
I'm being honest.
I think self doubt is,
you know,
instead of self doubt,
I would say questioning.
I think it's critical to question,
but it's certain stages.
If you're questioning all the time,
you have nothing but fear and doubt,
right?
You only believe something cause you
don't question it,
right?
Someone tells me,
Oh so and so talked behind your back
this.
And he'd go,
no,
they're my friend maybe ever do that.
Your belief,
your certain,
they're not going to do it so you don't
even entertain it.
But if two or three people tell you that
and they go,
wow,
good John,
really be doing this by my back.
I mean,
and you start questioning it.
You ever done that?
You've been upset with somebody,
you confront them and then you find out
it's all bullshit.
They didn't do anything wrong and you
feel like an idiot.
So,
so for me,
I think there's a time to question.
And so I organized that when I'm
beginning something,
I do that.
And my investments is a perfect example,
you know,
uh,
if you look at somebody,
you know,
uh,
like Richard Branson for example,
Richard is this giant risk taker,
right?
But he questioned,
he's got one question,
he questions within himself and everyone
else.
How are we gonna protect the downside?
It's his number one question.
You never believe it.
Cause I got risks.
His life when it comes to investments in
business,
he doesn't risk anything.
When he was,
he told me I was building virgin,
he's taking,
I'm British airlands and it's giant
outright at capitol.
I mean this could literally bankrupt I
and everybody said it would.
So he said,
okay,
how to protect the downside.
And he negotiated with Boeing for a year
and a half and convinced them that if he
went out of business,
if he was wrong and lost his business in
the first two years,
he could get back all the jabs and have
no liability whatsoever.
So his whole focus is asymmetrical risk
reward.
How do I take the least risk with the
most upside?
If I was going to say anything,
go entrepreneurs in this room,
the illusion that you've been taught is
that great entrepreneurs take giant
risks.
It's total bullshit.
There are some exceptions that have and
they gotten lucky,
but if you look at the ones that
consistently succeed,
they know the upside will take care of
itself.
They focus on how to protect the
downside.
And they take risks where they know I'm
taking a limited risk for an unlimited
upside.
So if I'm wrong,
I'm still okay.
You know,
I worked with Paul Tudor Jones,
one of the top 10 traders in the history
of the world,
and Paul,
I've worked with them,
I've coached now for 24 years.
He hasn't lost money in those 24 years
on his own personal training.
And during that time I've learned so
much from him and the biggest thing I
learned from him was this asymmetrical
risk reward that when he risks a dollar,
he wants to be certain,
he's going to make five where he doesn't
rest of the doubt.
He must be worth a dollar to make 10% or
20% you won't do that.
If you do that,
you're going to go broke because here's
what happens.
You risk a dollar to try to make five
and you're wrong,
risk another dollar,
and if you win,
you still win big.
You can be wrong four to five times and
still break even.
That's how the best in the world do it.
They don't do it by taking these
gigantic risks where everything's on the
line.
If it doesn't go perfectly,
you're out of business.
That's why most businesses go out.
You want to think of asymmetrical risk
reward
tutor Jones,
curiously as an aside,
was a classmate of mine at the
University of Virginia.
Wow,
man,
I met him there.
He would never remember it,
but a but a fascinating guy.
Uh,
another aside,
because you mentioned that he's a hedge
fund manager in Connecticut.
You did a brilliant interview with Ray
Dalio for,
I believe it was facebook not long ago.
And his book is really terrific,
called principles.
I recommend you all go get it.
Very,
very good.
It's one of the greatest business books
I've ever read because if you don't
know,
ray is in most of you know Warren
Buffet.
That's because Warren buffet is sweet
and shares and is public nature.
But Ray is actually most successful
investor of its type in the history of
the world.
He's returned more money to investors
and the Hedge Fund perspective than
anybody in history.
When I met Ray now 10 years ago,
you had of a $5 billion net worth for
him to talk to you.
You couldn't be a billionaire that's too
weak and you got to give them 100
million to start.
Now.
He won't take your money no matter who
you are.
When I went to go interview him the
first time,
the prime minister of China was talking
to him the phone,
he was coaching China on what to do with
their money.
That's how brilliant his hedge fund
people,
if you're familiar with rich people,
give them money.
Hedge Fund's a big one.
Might be,
let's say 20 billion.
He's 160 billion,
but go get his book.
He flew down to palm beach and my home
and it's called principles.
He said,
I want you to be the first person to
interview me and do it on,
on facebook live.
So I did,
but I love this man and he will show you
how we built from nothing.
You literally started with nothing and
he worked as a caddy.
Um,
he started when he was 26 years old and
a two bedroom apartment and now he's got
1800 employees,
160 billion.
He's 100 richest men in the world and
one of the top 10.
And they go meet.
But his insights about how to run a
business,
how to run your life,
we all need principles to guide our
decision making.
If you really think about it,
success is the result of good judgment,
right?
If you make great decisions,
you're going to succeed.
But where does good judgement comes
from?
You know,
good judgment,
awesome.
Often comes from experience and
experience often comes from bad
judgment,
right?
So what I found is the way to speed it
up,
way to have less of that bad judgment is
coming out of a,
think about that for a minute.
That's good.
All good?
Yeah.
So I found that the way to speed it up
is not learned through my own
experience,
but learn by modeling.
Others compress decades into days.
So if you can get an erase head,
no,
raised in a very private man through
Larry Decade,
but he's,
he's 68 years old.
He's a good friend and he's entering a
stage where he now wants to go public
for a short time,
give everybody knows and then disappear
cause he feels an obligation to give
back to the society and human beings
that have helped him to again.
So go pick it up and it'll be fantastic.
We had them at another event and he
talks about this idea of,
of radical transparency and yes,
how he runs his business.
It's a very different,
I'm not sure it would work for every
business,
but it certainly worked for him.
Let's go to uh,
uh,
set Torrie's question,
but so many people wanting your help.
What are the factors for you to select
who you privately train or mentor?
I said you're a busy guy,
you've got a time management thing.
I'm sure a lot of people would like a
piece of Tony Robbins mind.
How do you decide who whom you are going
to help?
Well,
first of all,
I try to do things online.
Now.
You know,
like I,
there's a zillion things on youtube,
so no one has to spend any money.
Anybody who wants to be inspired to do
that,
they only,
I don't like about that is it's random.
I'm a system guy,
like I know how to take you from here to
there.
So I have products that can do that for
people.
And then they have events and the events
have gotten bigger and bigger.
Now we do 10,
14,000 people in a weekend.
Um,
and so anybody can go who I coach or
people that I know by touching them,
I can touch millions more.
So when I work with a Marc Benioff at
salesforce,
you know,
in the early days,
mark sat in the front row,
came to three of my same seminars in a
row,
and I was like,
are you,
are you new?
Are you a little slow?
As a teaser,
there
marches as big as I am.
He stands up and I'm looking at this
guy,
I die.
And he goes,
you know,
my name is Marc Benioff.
And because of you,
you finally pushed me over the edge.
I'm gonna Start my own business.
I'm leaving Oracle,
I'm gonna Start this company called
salesforce.com and he said,
uh,
and you mark my words,
we're going to change business around
the world.
We're going to do $100 million in
business.
Well,
this year he's going to do 10 billion.
Right?
So he's grown a little bit,
but when you're around people like that,
you get to see what the distinctions are
that separate people.
You get to see what,
what makes them stand out and buy.
Coaching him,
I'm able to affect everybody,
not only all of him and his employees
because he's that kind of owner,
right?
He's a leader,
but also he's a leader in the social,
you know,
social community.
He's very conscious about that.
And everybody from facebook,
the apple to Ge,
the back end is salesforce.
So impacting him,
in fact,
some of the other people,
and maybe by just picked people who I
feel the need is and somebody stops me
in the street,
you know,
my wife will tell you I can't not help
and I got to help someone that I may
have limited time.
So then I'll invite them in a seminar or
send them a book or a package or
something so I can give them a guide to
go to the next level.
So I don't ever say no,
but I can't coach everybody one on one.
So I tried to do it in groups where
there was a wonderful anecdote I read
since you brought up Marc Benihoff that
I guess he was a guest at one of your
bed,
your home or resort in Fiji and middle
of the night you get he and all of the
other guests.
It is,
it goes to the question of how do you
overcome your fears?
Tell that story about Benny Hoff jumping
into the river river and what you didn't
tell him about the river.
Okay.
Well I have a home in Fiji.
I've been going there since I was 2124
years old.
So my favorite places in the world and
the people there are extraordinary.
You're carried as a child every day for
six months by someone 24 seven so we
talked about raising them,
you know,
being raised by a village.
It's true.
They're on there.
They sing in four part harmony when
they're four years old.
So when I went there,
I was touched by it and I went explored
this island and I was with this chief
and I,
they have this river that goes both ways
because it's this river where the ocean
comes in and it looks like out of Africa
or something you'd see down in South
America and eventually goes,
ms scary looking arrogant into a giant
wake.
But the tide is so fast it would just
take you.
And then your eight hours later when
reverses and goes back out.
So I was whipping missed one day and I
said,
are there any fish in there?
And the Ratu,
which is the main key points that goes a
little about that.
And we looked back and it's a giant
Manta rays slowly going under the
bridge.
So I said,
F it,
I'm doing this.
I just jumped in.
And then the thing took me and it took
me for a wild ass ride for about 20
minutes.
I end up this lake and then dumb ass me.
I didn't think about how the hell am I
going to get back.
He was so strong,
I couldn't swim against this.
I spent eight hours on this little
island airport.
So then I came back one time with a
friend,
it was nighttime and I was like,
you know,
they were talking about devil rock in
shark alley and all this shit.
I was like,
let's do it at night.
But I had a boat waiting for us
to bring us back,
Ben,
and it was scary as hell in all the,
you know,
all the phosphorescence going on.
What's like Pixie dust?
It's,
it's a wild experience flying fish to
scare the shit out of here.
They come by and so when,
when mark came,
he flew over and come spend a week with
me there.
I took him and woke him up and you have
to do when the tide is,
it was like two in the morning.
I woke them all up and so I got a
surprise for you.
Like what?
Just trust me.
Dragged them on.
You know what gear on him gave him wife
life preservers and then threw him off
and mark was freaking out and I grabbed
his hand and then we'll go on three one
we went on one.
If I can feel him,
he's as big as I tried to jump.
You might be hanging me out there.
There's a whole mum,
oh,
mark talks about that story a lot.
But overcoming fear cause you are
whatever you're afraid of.
It's never as much as you're afraid of.
Right.
You know,
it's how many things you've been afraid
of.
It never happened.
Right.
I remember things you do are afraid of,
if they do happen,
you just deal with them.
It's that old phrase,
you know,
coward dies.
1,000 deaths.
A courageous man.
I'm only once I discipline myself,
not perfectly,
but for the most part I don't worry
about shit til that happens.
You know?
I anticipate it,
but I don't worry about it.
You have stayed is everything.
I isn't.
That means state of mind.
How do you stay in a great state of
mind?
24 seven.
Should that even be your goal?
I think it's worthwhile to have as a
goal.
I don't think it's realistic.
24 seven whatever,
having a blurbs because we all have a 2
million year old brain.
Everything's roommates that I do too.
And it's not designed to make you happy.
It's designed to make you survive.
So if I said to all of you right now,
like what does that bring look for?
It looks for what can hurt you and it
exaggerates it.
And since there's no saber tooth tiger,
now it says,
what did people thinking of me?
Well,
my business make it.
Do I have enough money?
And these are all easy things to solve,
but our reactions in our gut and when we
let the fear part of our mind take over
that basically if the survival software,
if it runs you,
you're in trouble.
So a few years ago,
I actually lecture on this now.
I say,
you know,
you need to skills to have the quality
of life you want.
If you want an extraordinary life life
on your terms,
whatever your terms are,
he need to master the skill of the
science of achievement.
You've got to figure out how do I take
what I dream about and make it real?
And it's a science and you can model
other people and you can learn.
You can speed up.
I spent my lifetime doing that.
But the second skill and the one that
most people don't give enough value to
culturally is more important.
And that is,
you knew to Allston,
if you want an extraordinary life,
how many people you know that have
achieved and how many have done this?
Who has achieved the goal?
That was a big Ole,
you worked your ass off and you achieved
it and then your brain went,
is this all there is?
Who's had one of these moments?
Yeah,
almost everybody.
And that's worse than failing because
the low achievers miss riding where I'm
right.
So if you fail,
what are you gonna do?
You get back up,
try another approach.
You going eventually succeed.
You know it and your God if you're
really driven.
But if you succeed in your miserable,
now you're what I call technically
screwed,
right?
I mean,
because if you're not happy with what
you got,
I mean feeling you'd get up and do
something new but succeeding,
where do you go?
So I really believe you look at somebody
like,
um,
uh,
like somebody like say Robin Williams.
I think the loss of him was one of the
greatest losses we had.
He's loved worldwide.
Ask people all over the world last year
and China asked him in Japan and Sydney,
Australia throughout the US,
how many nos people,
how many of you loved,
don't let you if you liked it.
How many of you loved Robin Williams?
I'm curious,
keep your hands up.
Look around the room like 98%.
Only 2% assholes.
That didn't like her
Williams.
But
when I say this,
I didn't say,
like I said,
love.
And so here's a guy,
was he an overachiever?
He came to Hollywood ever when it comes
to Hollywood,
he said,
well,
my own show.
Oh yeah,
sure you are buddy.
How was old MR member the show?
What was it called?
Mork and mindy organ to old people in
this room.
Clearly he does mork and mindy,
but he also makes it the number one
show.
Then he says,
I'm going to have a beautiful family.
Does that.
Then he says,
I want to make more money than I could
spend.
He does that.
Then he says,
I want to make movies.
He does that.
Then he says,
I want to win an academy award for not
being funny is number one skill,
and he did it and then he hung himself
in his own home,
leaving his wife and children to find
his lifeless body.
Highly explained that I thought the
answer.
He made everybody happy but home.
Then his wife said he had lewy bodies
and upsets in his brain.
That's all true,
but he used drugs and alcohol his entire
life.
He suffered his entire life,
made everybody happy but himself and so
I love the guy.
I,
I might,
one of my birthdays,
I was at Ted and he did this talk was
very popular and he came to my birthday
party.
A bunch of guys took me out to dinner
that night and jumped on top of the
table and saying,
happy birthday as a Russian woman.
And then as a Chinese man,
and you know,
I've never lost a suicide knock on wood
out of thousands.
We've made films and followed up and I
had no idea that's where he was.
But I looked at him and I'm like that.
I say he's a warning.
As much as we all loved him,
even more so because we left him,
I know none of you are going to kill
yourself.
I'm not worried about that.
But a lot of people live a long time,
but they don't really live,
you know,
because they let,
they let their stress and the
frustration,
you know,
I always say achievers don't get
fearful.
We're all achievers and they don't get
We just get stressed.
Stress is the achiever word for fear.
Because when I say to you,
what are you stressing about?
What I gotta do this,
I gotta make this thing happen.
What if you know,
well,
I got to,
what of your own?
It'll fall apart.
What if it falls apart,
then it will fail.
What if it fails?
Then I'm a failure.
What if you're a failure?
And now if I follow the trail of your
stress,
it'll take me to your deepest fear.
And the only way to have your life work
is the face that fear and push through
it.
What is courage?
Courage does not mean you're not afraid
of means you're afraid and you do it
anyway.
You're scared shitless,
but you do it anyway.
But I think if you're going to succeed
at the highest level,
you've got to face those fears.
Leads right to the next question.
Uh,
based on your experience,
what are the top three characteristics
to have in order to be successful for
these type of people?
What does success look like?
What does it feel like?
What are the characteristics that can
get you there?
What success looks like and feels like?
It's different for everyone because we
all define success in a different way.
So I leave that to that.
But what does it take to succeed that I
can tell you,
cause I can be an idiot at this point.
But when you've been with,
you know,
50 million people,
4 million in live seminars for days and
nights and days and nights.
I know that whatever we do,
it's the result of our patterns.
It's not us.
There are certain patterns.
It'll make you angry.
They'll make you frustrated,
they'll make you pissed off.
And there's certain patterns of thinking
and feeling and using your body that'll
make you playful and fun and grateful
and excited and passionate.
And if you think it's you could,
you've done a pattern so long,
it's hard to change yourself,
but it's easy to change your path.
What are the patterns come from?
We learned them through our
conditioning.
When you first born,
you can do anything in your lab.
Do you can,
you know,
scream,
yell,
go to the bathroom,
your pants.
Try that when you're 30 see if it works,
right?
You know,
but you learn very quickly as time goes
by,
your love for nothing as a baby,
right?
Your love,
no matter what you do because your
mother is,
you know,
got oxytocin.
She's drug natural drug in her body.
Men Get it too.
But let me get 10 times as much.
That's why a healthy woman cannot leave
her child.
A healthy man can't.
But a woman can.
I have cheese,
biochemically healthy.
And so you look at this and you say,
you know,
what are the three things needed?
I can tell you what they are the number
one,
I love intelligence,
live wickedly intelligent people.
I tried to hire as many of them as
possible,
learn from them.
But what's more valuable than
intelligence is hunger.
Do you find,
if you looked at,
what's the calming down in between
Richard Branson,
Mark Benioff,
you give me your list of whoever it is.
I guarantee if you dig underneath,
their hunger has never gone away.
Some people get hungry cause they got a
goal to achieve something or get in a
swimsuit by a certain date or some
stuff.
But that's when it,
that's when the identity change,
right?
These are people that are like myself.
I'm hungry today at 57 more than I was
at 26 you know,
I can,
I,
I'm feeling me out and when I say
hungry,
I'm hungry to contribute,
to learn,
to grow,
to make a difference.
I'll never settled west when I can be or
do or share or give a create and
everyone I know that's successful.
That's the driving force because without
hunger you can get the skill.
With that hunger,
you can figure it out.
Well that there are a lot of very smart
people who can't fight their way out of
a paper bag and a pragmatic way.
And they got,
you know,
great,
great transcripts and shit like that.
I went to Harvard one time and I spoke
and right before I spoke,
they had voted at Harvard business
school to not release anyone's
transcripts to the recruiters of the
businesses coming in to block it.
And the argument was,
your education is more than just your
grades.
And I went to Buzzer.
I got up there.
First of all,
they said,
you know Tony,
the first,
you know that I expect to be,
you know,
thousand people.
There are a couple thousand people
there.
And they said,
no,
no.
Bill Gates is here.
We have 300 people.
It's going to be much smaller.
But we ended up with about 1200 people
standing room only.
And they gave me 30 minutes.
And of course I went three hours.
I did.
No one laughed.
And,
but one of the first things I did,
I said,
what is this bullshit?
I'm reading this in the paper that day.
I said,
listen,
I'm not trying to be disrespectful,
but you been disrespectful to each
other.
I said,
you know,
if you're not willing to show your
transcripts,
I think I agree with you,
your career,
who you are as more than just your,
your degree here.
But you chose Harvard for a reason.
And there are people here that have
worked around the clock and gotten,
you know,
4.0 and you got yourself a 2.6 and
you're going to block them cause there's
more of you than the 4.0 it's not gonna
work that way.
When you get in business,
when you going a business,
you guys who are doing this right now,
you're going to be judged on one thing.
Results and your grades are the results
in this context.
And if you think your grades are not up
and convince me as the interviewer that
the grades are a part of it,
but there's so much more united.
If you can't do that,
you're never gonna make it.
I said,
you guys,
you can do.
Anybody voted for that.
Just count on a future that is full of
pain.
And the room was like,
you know,
it was,
it was pretty intense,
I guess.
I thought it was pretty soft personally.
And then all of a sudden people stood up
and he did a standing ovation and people
said,
this is bullshit because this is what
happens sometimes in a democracy.
Sometimes in a democracy,
the lowest level standard is what
becomes natural.
We're seeing it right now on the
political side,
we're seeing people that you know and
Berkeley home of free speech,
people throwing things,
burning things,
destroying things,
who are supposed to be liberals,
who should be open for open speech and
then you see conservatives,
they're just as dumb sing things that
inflaming people.
It's,
it's not one side or the other.
It's us as a society.
We gotta shift that.
We got to go from demonization to
saying,
let's say it's a fight over guns,
very emotional fight.
What's the problem?
We demonize upside.
Nobody in this room,
whether you're pro gun or against Gun,
whether you want gun regulation or not,
there's nobody in this room that doesn't
want their children or their friends or
their family safe and protected.
We just disagreed.
People disagree on how,
and if we can start with what we agree
on,
we can actually make progress.
But today there is no progress because
we now also augment this,
the social media and we augment it with
a regular media and think about it.
The media is not here to inform you.
They here to startle you.
We all know if we say something
inflaming,
you're going to talk about it,
share it on social media,
and they got a multiplied effect.
It's all about advertising.
So you have to really discern yourself.
Today.
You have to understand it's the wild
west,
not only on the Internet,
but on television as well.
And you have to decide if you're an
independent thinker,
what is really right and maybe be part
of the solution instead of another
person that attacks the right or the
left Donald Trump or whoever it is that
can be attacking.
And there's lots of people that are easy
to attack,
but attacking doesn't change your
approve anything.
So in my opinion,
we,
we gave you 45 minutes.
Would anybody here mind if we went a
little longer?
Would you mind if we went a little loans
here?
So let me five or six more hours,
five or six more hours.
We'll bring the bar inside as well.
We'll do,
uh,
so,
so I want to finish what I said just for
one second.
Please don't answer this person's
question,
which was three things.
So we got through one hunger,
okay,
let's go fast.
Hunger is the number one.
I think the number two is having a
mission larger than yourself because
it's kind of like having a child,
right?
You know,
having a child was a very exciting thing
and then you have a child and you go,
what did I do?
Sometimes really,
uh,
same thing with the business,
right?
You know,
you've got to really be able to have
something you're doing it for,
that's more than you can in the early
days.
The business,
it doesn't really make you any money and
you work your tail off.
So you need pride of ownership.
You need joy,
you need a mission.
And I really believe until you find
something that you care about more than
yourself,
you'll never discover what you're
capable of because we're all doing more
for others that we love or respect than
we'll ever do for ourselves.
That's part of the beauty of being a
human.
Most of them to do more for our kids,
for example,
than other people.
And then I think the third thing is you
got mission in hunger is you really have
to become obsessed with strategies
because strategies can save you so much
time.
The wrong strategy.
And you know,
I'll get a stupid metaphor if you said
your number one goal is to see a sunset
and then you start running east as fast
as you can.
I don't give a shit how positive you
are.
I don't care how hard you work,
I don't care how long you been putting
into,
you've got the wrong strategy,
but the right strategy in business and
in life can save you a decade.
And someone else may have spent again a
decade figuring it out to trial and
error and then they figured it out.
You might be a learn it in six weeks or
six months or six days or six hours.
So I think that would be my third.
So let me ask you a question that may be
a little off point but,
but I hope helpful.
A lot of people in this room and a lot
of people in the world want to follow
their passion.
Okay.
But they've also got to put food on the
table and pay the rent and pay the the
bills.
How do you do both at the same time?
How do you build,
follow,
have your mission,
have your passion and do that when you
know the world is a tough place,
hard to make a living or to pay the
bills,
places expensive.
How do you do that?
How do you thread that needle?
Well,
it depends on who you're dealing with,
right?
If the person is entrepreneurial and
they asked me this question,
I always tell them,
you know,
you've got to take care of your kids.
You've got to pay the bills.
And I said,
but you know,
tell me when you work.
And they tell me,
well you know,
I work nine to five or eight to five and
I'm exhausted.
And they also said,
well what are you doing with the other
eight hours?
I mean cause that's what I did.
I worked as a janitor all my long
millburn everything else.
I could compress time there because it
was based on results,
not time.
So if I could do a great job in shorter
time,
I have that time.
But then you know what I started doing
between,
you know,
seven o'clock at night and two in the
morning,
which is pretty much at the time I work.
That's when I was developing myself,
getting the skills,
learning,
educating,
starting the business.
So I think people just have to realize
it's gut wrenching process.
It's not an entrepreneurship is not for
everybody.
Most people fail.
Entrepreneurship,
the vast majority fail,
you know,
96% of 10 years.
But what happens after 10 years?
All clear sailing after that.
Anybody Remember Lehman Brothers?
They ran a century that gross revenues
over a century of more than a trillion
with a t dollars.
That's when went through their bank
accounts over that century and they're
gone.
So I don't think it's right for every,
but I think you have to really be clear,
is your personality the right
personality?
If you're going to begin in this area,
and then if you're going to work for
somebody else,
you can still be company free.
But that means you've got to stop being
a consumer and become an owner of our
under entrepreneurs.
You want to own businesses,
right?
Get out of just the,
you know,
don't just own an iphone on the company
and not just apple obviously.
How do you keep your energy up and your
enthusiasm up?
I,
you know,
I need to do it.
I'm wired for it.
You know what Miss,
it's my nature to some extent.
But also the other part is I get to see
results.
I mean,
who here has ever been touched by my
work before?
I'm curious.
Anybody in this room.
So look around the room and then I just,
how's it hard to be inspired when I'm in
a room?
Then a third or 40% or 50% have used my
work.
And so people come up to me every day,
dozens of people a day.
If I'm traveling and they told me the
most amazing stories outside my children
and my wife,
that's probably the greatest gift of my
life.
I never get tired of hearing it.
And it just makes me want to deliver
more,
give more,
have more impact.
You get the last word.
Tell them what you want to know.
Well,
if you're entrepreneurs out there,
here's what I'd say to you.
I'd say,
don't be so damn hard on yourself.
I know that sounds counter to being an
achiever,
but when you're beating yourself up,
you're sucking out the energy and need
to move forward.
It's kind of like I always tell people,
there's so much energy and I've built
mine.
I do a lot of things to build my energy,
be incredibly strong and have really
strong endurance because to me,
energy is life.
If you don't have strong energy,
I could do anything.
But even after we look at that energy,
it only goes so many places.
So if your energy's being caught up,
if you take energy and a business and
you pour it into external marketing,
going out and reaching people and adding
value,
the business is going to grow.
But if their inner conflicts in that
business between people,
then the energy's being sucked in here
and less energy is going out there.
The business is going to have problems.
That's also true of you.
If you allow your disappointments to
create these inner conflicts and fears
and you let them run wild within you,
they're going to suck the energy out.
You need to go to the next level in your
business.
You have to discipline your
disappointment.
Now,
you know mine is the 92nd rule.
So watch this.
Try something real fast.
Look around this room.
I'm going to give you a task.
Look around this room and see
everything.
It's Brown.
I'm going to test you in a moment.
Look behind you.
Look around you.
Look clothing like the people at
anything that's Brown,
Brown,
Brown.
Record recorded in your mind.
Close your eyes.
Now with your eyes closed,
tell me everything you saw just now.
That was red.
If you see more brown than red,
say I open your eyes.
Look for red.
Now really look for red.
Look for it.
Anywhere you can find a look around.
You.
Look beside you.
Look at front back.
How many found more red this time?
Raise your hand.
If you did say,
ah,
why did you find more red this time that
you told me to seek and Ye shall find,
but here's what's amazing.
Seek and you shall find.
Even if it's not there,
I'll prove it to you.
How many saw beige shit called it brown
just to feel successful?
How many saw burgundy and called it red?
Just download pieces,
so if you think you're a jerk or someone
else's,
a jerk,
you're going to cover it.
You're going to change it.
You're going to find the jerkiness and
them.
You're going to find the jerk in you.
It's really important that you manage
your mental,
emotional state because you are the
business.
If you are the leader,
your responsibility,
your job,
your opportunity,
your privilege is to be able to truly
lead and you cannot lead.
If you're living in fear,
you cannot lead in a place of constant
uncertainty.
We all have uncertainty at times,
but if you watch an athlete go out to
shoot a free throw or kick her in the
NFL to go kick the ball.
How many were seen that person?
They're about to kick it.
They're about to shoot.
You go,
they're going to miss it and you know
they're going to miss it.
Who's experienced this before?
How did you know?
You could see in their body that they're
missing the core ingredient,
absolute certainty.
You've got the great skills in the
world,
but when you lose that certainty,
the athlete goes down.
That's usually when I get the call.
I got to rewire them and get them back
where they can execute at that level.
So be kind to yourself,
as Corny as that sounds,
not to be kind to yourself.
And so there's more energy available to
solve the problems and to build the
business and the meet your mission
because the time you're beating yourself
up,
you're trying to prove yourself,
you really care.
But meanwhile what you're doing is
sucking the energy out of your growth.
I had somebody who,
who embezzle some money when I was a
tiny company,
all I want to tell me this $3 million
and the guy in a quarter million dollars
and I was seven and $58,000 in debt and
thought I was in profit.
And in those days,
no,
every told me I have to go bankrupt.
And I remember I was just like so angry.
There's so much anger because my
business was like my child,
this guy tried to kill my child,
you know,
so I was chasing him in Mexico so I
could beat the hell out of him,
put him in prison.
And um,
and then I realized in the middle of
this stuff,
I got to let go of this because while
I'm busy being angry and pissed off,
the business is gonna go under.
I'm chasing birds.
When we do,
when it gets to the bird,
I got to focus on how to have the value.
And so take your energy.
That's all you have in this life and
invested in the things you love and
those you love and the mission of Your
Business and in your clients.
If you fall in love with what you do,
who you do with and who you do it for,
there'll be no limit to your impact.
But you gotta be willing to do it for
decades because it's all bullshit.
Maybe you'll hit the lucky thing and
don't happen in 12 months,
but even if you don't,
even if you did,
you know,
uh,
I've got a friend who's one of my
partners in the La Aafc and so forth in
a chat and started youtube for example,
and one point $6 billion in what,
18 months,
24 months,
that type of thing,
if not always the best thing.
Because ultimately in life,
whenever you meet people at succeeded,
almost always we talk about the toughest
times and laugh and remember because in
order to have the foreground,
you need a background and to appreciate
the foreground,
you need the background.
So I found that the most difficult times
have been the best times because they've
made me appreciate what my life is like
today.
And I'll be able to take care of
yourselves.
And I hope today,
this whole day,
all the speakers and hopefully a little
of our conversation has been helpful
too.
And I thank you for letting me address
you.
Thank you so much.